you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's program
changing the course of global warming
scientists show how a future without
meat could cut global emissions by
two-thirds
the gas supply crisis slows europe's
efforts to reduce coal and cut emissions
while renewable energy continues to grow
and a small but vital step to help
protect koala populations as the first
southern joey to be born in europe
emerges from his mother's pouch
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now scientists searching for ways to cut
damaging greenhouse gas emissions fast
enough to limit global warming have
turned their attention to animal
agriculture one study by experts in
california claims veganism holds the
answer
they've calculated that by stopping
farming animals for food greenhouse gas
emissions would fall by the equivalent
of a 68 reduction in carbon dioxide
but could the general public ever be
convinced our science correspondent
thomas more reports
it's little surprise that scientists
behind one of the top vegan food brands
want to get rid of all animal
agriculture but plant trees in the empty
fields do it in just 15 years and you
have a radical climate plan taken
seriously enough to be published in a
peer-reviewed journal
they calculate the combined effect on
global warming would be the same as
reducing carbon dioxide emissions by
two-thirds i think the results are solid
and i would encourage scientists to
look at the results skeptically and but
with an open mind and draw their own
conclusions and
i think they'll
they'll realize that
this is the biggest opportunity
uh to turn back the clock on climate
change that we're ever going to have
and we should jump on it the scientists
from two of america's top universities
say the animal industry is responsible
for 16 percent of greenhouse gas
emissions rewild in the land as forest
would remove 800 billion tons of carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere and that
would pause rising emissions for 30
years
but other climate scientists say it's
far too simplistic we need to be
addressing fossil fuel use
and we also need to be addressing our
diets but there is a danger that this is
kind of okay the world can go vegan we
can carry on driving our cars using
petrol which is which is really very
misleading dangerously so the plan would
also wind up many carnivores
meat is still such a big part of the
national diet that even the committee on
climate change the government's advisers
say a more realistic target is reducing
consumption by 35 percent by 2050
is this then steak with less guilt
claire hill moves her cattle to fresh
grazing every day the soil stores more
carbon offsetting some of the methane
from the cows and it's better for
biodiversity too less meat and better
meat in this part of the world in the
western world less and better meat more
and better vegetables has to be a kind
of mantra that we start to look to
but vegan only i
am not sure that the exclusion of
animals completely from our ecosystem is
going to bring the benefits um that that
we need but the vegan scientists say
animal agriculture takes up a third of
the earth's land area and that's not
sustainable thomas more sky news
efforts to reduce the amount of coal
power in use have been hampered by the
surge in gas prices new analysis of
electricity market data found that
increasing levels of renewable energy
are being used to replace gas rather
than coal in the european union and this
is putting ambitions to cut emissions
and limit global warming to 1.5 degrees
at risk
so coal usage in the eu dropped by just
three percent in 2019 to 2021 compared
to a decline of 29
in the two previous years
use of renewable energy has expanded in
europe in the last two years but while
more than half of this additional energy
has replaced gas power only a sixth has
replaced coal
and in the uk solar power generated 3.8
percent of the overall electricity
supply in 2021 less than half the amount
of leading eu countries
in europe however solar generation is on
the rise and it's not just in sunny
countries in 2021 nearly 10 percent of
spain's electricity came from solar
energy and the same is true of the
netherlands and just over nine percent
of germany's power supply came from
solar energy
so why is solar power booming across
much of the eu but not in the uk well
joining us now is phil mcdonald the
chief operating officer of the think
tank ember which conducted this study uh
phil mcdonald welcome to you
sona taking off then on the continent
why is that not the case in the uk
so yeah as as you mentioned it really is
uh it's not to do with how sunny the
countries are it really is to do with a
explicit choice by the government so
it's it's a choice to to back it with
policy um rather than just where the
sunshine is as we're seeing netherlands
and germany very similar countries on a
very similar latitude to the uk are
doing extremely well with uh with solar
and continuing to grow and the uk is
stuck uh stagnant at this this level
around four percent of uh of power
demand and it really isn't it's a
government choice the uk however
outperforms many of its european
neighbors on wind power so do we need to
focus on solar as we race towards
meeting our climate goals
we're going to need both and the useful
thing about is solar is that you can you
can use it very uh close to where the
electricity is being actually used so
you're you
the real opportunities to be putting
solar on on roofs and we're seeing this
in germany the new coalition government
has committed to
every new build home is going to have
solar on the roof and that makes a huge
difference to electricity demand
meanwhile you think that the rise in gas
prices would be good news as far as
renewables are concerned you think
everyone would move from gas to
renewables so what's actually happening
what's actually going on
yeah so we've seen uh there's obviously
a global energy price shock happening at
the minute and it's it's around gas and
we're seeing that
instead of uh renewables for the last
decade have been eating into coal and
reducing coal which has been great for
the climate now they're reducing gas
instead and uh coal is being given a bit
of a stay of execution and that really
puts europe off track for its climate
goals uh which is a real worry well yes
and cop 26 we saw leaders agree to phase
down the use of coal i mean coal use is
still going down isn't it and if gas is
coming down as well
how worried should we be
we we should still be worried we need to
have uh even these kind of small
declines are
not good enough to get europe uh
entirely fossil free we know that by
2035 we need to be coal and gas free
across all of europe and uh this just
doesn't put us on that trajectory these
kind of small declines aren't going to
get us there it needs to move much
faster and obviously the way to do that
is to deploy much more wind and solar as
quickly as possible well phil mcdonald
thanks very much indeed for your time
thank you
now for some of the day's other climate
news and it's been revealed that
brazil's environmental agency spent less
than half of its budget for climate
enforcement last year despite soaring
levels of destruction in the amazon
rainforest deforestation in brazil's
amazon rainforest hit a 15-year high in
2021 clearing an area larger than the
u.s state of connecticut
brazilian president jaya bolsonaro has
often spoken out against what he calls
overzealous enforcement of environmental
laws
a mega flash bolt of lightning spanning
nearly 500 miles across three u.s states
has set the record for the most
far-reaching single flash the lightning
occurred in april 2020 extending over
477 miles through texas louisiana and
mississippi he beat the old 2018 record
set in brazil by almost 40 miles
sand dunes that were once used as a
dumping ground for waste tobacco are to
be rejuvenated as a haven for wildlife
thousands of tons of wet tobacco leaf
was tipped onto the site in merseyside
known as tobacco cliffs between the 50s
and 70s the national trust aims to
transform the two hectare stretch of
land into a refuge for rare animals
including natajak toads the uk's loudest
amphibians
new research has found that keeping
global warming to 1.5 degrees above
pre-industrial levels will still be
catastrophic for coral reefs
scientists from the university of leeds
have found more than 90 percent of
tropical coral reefs will suffer
frequent and intolerable heat stress
their number one threat even under
climate warming limits in the paris
agreement over half a billion people's
livelihoods and food security rely on
coral reefs experts claim their survival
will require significant and urgent
action
globally and a baby southern koala born
at longleat safari park has emerged from
its mother's pouch for the first time
the joey is the first ever southern
koala to be born in europe a major
milestone for the species kuala numbers
in the wild were hit drastically by the
devastating bushfires in australia in
2019 which scientists say was made 30
more likely because of climate change
the reason behind also bringing them all
the way from south australia to here um
for a magnitude of reasons obviously we
saw those devastating bushfires um
before coverage um
and also just in general the genetic
poor and diversity lacking and so in
general just overall educating learning
hopefully enhancing our knowledge of
this amazing species we found out to
start with that we may have something
going on around middle of september um
from that um we saw a little bit of uh
changing violence behavior she started
distancing herself from burke
and basically
lounging around a lot more um we had a
little look and hey presto managed to
see a little bit of activity in the
pouch
that process from the birth to the
getting in the pouch would have been
around
roughly 30 to 36 days being pregnant
from that has been in the pouch she's
been settling on violent mum's milk and
it's now actually transitioning onto
more solid food um at around six months
old so it's doing very well it's getting
fluffier by the day and um
it's growing from shrimp
with the growing bushfires becoming more
and more prominent unfortunately in
places like south australia where these
speak the amazing species in front
sadly are putting more and more pressure
on the species are of the effect of the
population but also bringing them closer
together
and sadly overall
they are getting affected by this so
climate change is an issue
we're getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
climate scientist dr ella gilbert and
carbon footprinting expert mike
berners-lee so good evening to both of
you nice to see you both
so easy january is over with a
record-breaking 600 000 people taking
part this year and earlier in the show
we heard about what would happen under a
somewhat unlikely scenario if everyone
decided to go vegan and land was
returned to its natural state greenhouse
gas emissions could be reduced by nearly
70 percent and mike this report that's
just come out suggests that huge change
could be achieved through ditching
animal agriculture so do you think this
should become a main priority now as we
race to reach our climate targets
well whilst there's still a bit of
scientific uncertainty around some of
the details of exactly what causes what
was absolutely clear-cut
is that cutting our meat and dairy by a
lot in our diet is uh is going to make a
big difference to climate change whether
68 as reported in this uh you know in
this paper is the exact figure um you
know
remains slightly unclear but it's it's
definitely a key driver and it's not
just
from a climate perspective it's also
just as important from a biodiversity
perspective and also if you even if you
just want to uh feed the world and
provide everybody with access to
um a healthy nutritious diet that also
becomes a lot easier if you dramatically
reduce the amount of meat and dairy so
whether we need to absolutely be purist
and cut it to zero
i personally don't think i'd advocate
that but deep cuts i think they're
they're pretty uncontentious now yeah
dr ella gilbert i think i might say you
are vegan aren't you do you think that
everyone else should follow suit like
you and cut out meat and dairy all
together
i am vegan i have been for about 10
years but i think the thing i often say
to people is that it's not about this
binary choice between you know eating
meat three times a day and being
completely vegan it's a it's a spectrum
as mike was saying completely cutting
out
all animal products overnight is not
necessarily something that will go down
particularly well or that is necessary i
think it's always about having a balance
and saying we know that
the climate and environmental
uh impacts of the meat industry and also
to an extent of dairy are huge um but
it's about kind of phasing out and
reducing the amount of consumption that
we all have and so that we can have that
positive impact on the environment i
don't think it's necessarily as kind of
a clear-cut as saying you have to go
vegan tomorrow i think it's a lot more
palatable and to lots of people if you
give them the choices and you help them
to reduce or to transition away from
meat and more kind of damaging
environmentally damaging products
towards a more sustainable alternative
well yes because mike some people really
might not like the idea of being
lectured and told how to change
something as fundamental as their diet i
mean do you think that people
do
hate being told what to do in ways like
that when they'll say but hang on a
minute we've got whole countries that
are
getting all their power from coal for
example what difference is it going to
make if i give up my burger
well nobody likes being told what to do
about anything but there's plenty of
opportunity in this as uh you know we're
talking about a
over a period of time a cultural change
and educational change a few decades ago
it used to be that for most people they
could probably become more healthy uh if
they eat more meat and dairy actually
that's not the case at the moment most
people would become
more healthy if they had less meat and
dairy
the taste and quality
of the
non-meat and dairy products that are on
the market at the moment you know are
going up and up and up so you know it's
just a question of changing habit a
little bit and i think many of the
underlying drivers that used to make
people used to give um status to meat
and dairy
are no longer relevant and actually a
lot of people if they understood more
about exactly how most of the meat and
dairy that we produce in the world
is produced actually would want less of
it so i think you know i think this
change is waiting to happen and i think
with the climate change committee's 35
target by 2035 i think they are
dramatically under-egging uh both the
opportunity and the need for deeper cuts
than that uh it doesn't have to be
instant okay and as we've just heard you
know it doesn't have to be a hundred
percent so there's nothing to be scared
about and most people find i think that
as they start to change their habits
their preferences change with them as
well and and
what do you think about this
conversation happening in in richer
western countries like our own i mean
it's a different matter for some poorer
countries isn't it to
start talking about veganism
yeah it's a matter of choice and i think
in lots of nations where the dominant
protein source is less easy to kind of
switch to a vegan alternative um i'm
thinking of places where there's a heavy
reliance on fish for instance i think
that would be a more challenging thing
and then there's also the kind of
climate justice angle where you you can
talk about okay in developed countries
we've got a lot of historical
responsibility for driving climate
change why should we then lump the
burden of lifestyle change onto
countries who have less historical
responsibility
but i think it's it's kind of a nuanced
argument i think as a
global society we need to make these
changes to
really accelerate the amount of climate
action that we are taking and absolutely
every single thing that we can throw at
the problem we should be and that
includes cutting fossil fuel use that
includes
switching to more plant-based diets and
that includes a whole suite of other
things that no doubt we will hear about
okay let's move on to our next topic
shall we because the uk isn't known for
its sunshine but the think tank ember
has argued that the uk could be
generating more solar power from this
renewable source and last year solar
power made up twice as much of the
netherlands electricity mix compared to
the uk despite having a similar number
of sunny days i probably not very many
so are we making the most of our
sunshine ella what do you think could we
be doing more as far as solar is
concerned do you think
absolutely
if you just have to look at the the
statistics and how much we're lagging
behind to make that judgment i would say
um i think the discussion around kind of
switching from
gas to renewables instead of taking coal
out of our electricity mix just
highlights that problem we need to make
a transition away from fossil fuels we
need to very very fast and it seems a
bit of a missed opportunity to not be
rolling out these kinds of proven
technologies that we have already at our
fingertips
but mike we are rolling out the proven
technology of wind power aren't we i
mean we
we
compared to our competitors or not our
competitors our neighbours i should say
in on the continent
we probably do much more as far as wind
power is concerned do we need to worry
about solar as well
well we need to press all the buttons as
hard as we can it's got to be a rapid
transition yes it's true we're doing a
bit better on wind compared to other
countries you know in relation to our
solar but it's also true to say we could
do a lot better with our solar so you
know if even if you just look at rooftop
solar it's such a shame when you see a
new house built and it's got a sunflow a
south facing roof and only half of that
roof is filled with solar panels what
was wrong with the other half you know
there's there are some simple things we
could do much better on solar it's also
true to say that for the uk actually the
balance of renewables between wind and
solar is going to be somewhat different
for than for other countries so if you
compare us to australia we have only one
200th of the sunlight per person
compared to australia but we've got
really good wins so there is a case for
a bit more wind compared to
compared to compared to solar relative
to some other countries but still we
could be pressing the button uh harder
on solar power and we absolutely should
despite the pressure on land that we've
got as a sort of you know quite densely
populated country with not brilliant
sunlight compared to some others we
could still do a lot more and how should
that happen is this about more subsidies
to encourage people to put solar panels
on their roof
i think yeah there should be some kind
of incentive to make it easy um i mean
i'm not a complete expert when it comes
to the policy and energy particularly
but it should be something that could be
accessible for for most people and i
think also for you know landlords to be
incentivized to put solar panels on
their roofs for councils to put it on
their social housing as well as relying
on homeowners to actually
see the benefits of themselves and put
them on their roofs i think it has to be
kind of a blanket across the whole
whole of society to incentivize the
rapid deployment of solar technologies
okay well we must leave it there dr ella
gilbert mike berners-lee always
fascinating to get your take on things
thanks very much indeed
so that's it from today but tomorrow
i'll be joined by fatima ibrahim from
the green new deal uk and co-founder of
global optimism tom rivet carnac but for
now thanks for watching i'll see you
next time
[Music]